blaise renaud bonsoir bienvenue à 24 60
ans soit est ce qu'on peut dire ça a été
une semaine très chargée de dire une
grosse semaine pour vous annonce mardi
donc de la chad archambault qui sera
valide et éventuellement ou non par le
bourg la concurrence mais à 13h
aujourd'hui annonce comme qui le
pressent très laconique entente à
l'amiable avec des médias importants
distributeurs donc de livres dont vous
avez fait la paix avec d'hi-media fin du
litige
effectivement on dit comme vous l'avez
lu dans le communiqué qu'on s'engage à
ne pas commenter ce règlement là et les
détails de l'entente toutefois on a été
heureux effectivement cette semaine
l'annoncé coup sur coup l'acquisition
d'arch hambourg sujette à l'approbation
du bureau et ensuite ce règlement avec
des médias qui durait depuis presque
quatorze mois maintenant
ouais confié avec des médias je ne vous
demanderai pas de commenter l'entente
mais peut-être le contexte la pertinence
à ce moment ci de cette entente est ce
que selon vous cette entente était
nécessaire pour que vous soyez vous
apparaissez comme raisonnable en tout
cas après la transaction avec quebecor
ou jude law la concurrence en vous
montrant comme les libraires raisonnable
près respecté la loi du livre ce n'est
pas le contexte dans lequel ça c'est
fait on a avisé dès le début qu à nos
yeux c'est un conflit entre deux
entreprises privées vous savez renaud
bray à plusieurs centaines de
fournisseurs avec qui elle gère des
affaires sur une base quotidienne depuis
50 ans maintenant sans conflit ici on a
eu un litige avec un partenaire
historique de renaud bray qui est un
joueur important de la chaîne du livre
je pense que c'est une heureuse chose
pour tous que ce soit résolu
effectivement c'était quelque chose qui
pénalisait autant des éditeurs que des
auteurs que renault briques d'hi-media
donc c'est pour le mieux donc les
perdants écoutez je pense que comme dans
chaque chicane ya des perdants je pense
qu'il faut aussi regarder vers l'avenir
aujourd'hui de voir ce qu'on peut
construire en établissant un dialogue
qui a quand même exister pendant des
décennies et des décennies jusqu'à ce
litige la casquette du média jeu
travaillant sur le dossier avec facile
est de recouvrer un moment d'une fin
heureuse dans les années 90 enfants à
400 mille dollars 10 médias qui existe
aussi en fonction de ce que vous avez
appelé la chaîne du livre une loi de
1985 qui distribue les rôles dans cette
écoute certains parlent d'écosystèmes du
livre un joueur dit on est essentielle
mais qui pour vous ne devrait pas
exister alors conséquences de cette
entente
vous allez respectives de 12 un
communiqué les règles du jeu une
certaine manière mais allez-vous
continueront leur travail et pour faire
sauter ce maillon de la chaîne
écoutez en deux mots parce que vous
abordez deux problèmes dans une question
si vous permettez donc d'une part et à
l'historique de renaud bray qui s'est
effectivement restructuré
vers le milieu des années 90 par la
suite faut quand même pas oublier que
renault aurait aussi fait l'acquisition
des chaînes champigny et garneau qui
était à ce moment là toutes les deux
déficitaires et que on a réussi à créer
aujourd'hui ce fleuron qui est devenu
renaud bray qui n'est pas la compagnie
qu'elle était en 95 d'une nouvelle
compagnie et qui a permis au bénéfice de
tout un lot d'acteurs de l'industrie et
de la clientèle et de l'ensemble des
milieux culturels de favoriser un
attachement et un développement culturel
au québec
donc je pense qu'une somme toute
renouveau est un succès que wikimedia pu
connaître des jours difficiles avec
renaud bray comme ses autres
fournisseurs et plus qu'après ils ont
connu de très bons jours avec renaud
bray maintenant au ski de ma vision de
l'industrie du livre de la loi 51 série
jt relativement transparent il ya deux
ans lorsque la commission sur la
réglementation du prix du livre
j'ai dit que je souhaitais que soit
remise en question le système qui
prévaut aujourd'hui parce que
effectivement c'est un système qui a été
établi en 1980 avant l'internet avant
les télécommunications avant l'existence
des chaînes de livres alors que les
éditeurs n'étaient pas aussi regrouper
qu'ils le sont aujourd'hui vous aviez
des maisons indisposition indépendante à
l'époque beaucoup plus qu'aujourd'hui
idem pour les distributeurs donc ce que
j'ai dit à l'époque s'il fallait revoir
les rôles et je le pense encore vous le
pensez encore on peut partir d'aller
travailler à cela vous avait même dit la
chaîne du livre affaires telles qu'elles
existent est une ineptie vous voulez
modernise
vous le monde du livre des librairies et
donc vous tenez toujours à éliminer les
maillons vous aimeriez vous comme
libraire faire ce qu'on peut faire dans
d'autres commerces c'est à dire en ligne
vous approvisionner directement chez le
producteur dont vous aimeriez aller
directement au bout chez les éditeurs
vous l'avez fait en europe d'hôtel vous
avez acheté directement en europe en
contournant si on veut la chaîne du
livre incontournable distributeurs c'est
ce que vous aimeriez au fond sans
rentrer dans les détails ce que j'ai dit
c'est qu'il fallait créer un système qui
soit viable pour tout le monde avec de
nouveaux impératifs et qui reconnaissent
la réalité d'aujourd'hui en 2015 avec
des entreprises qui paient des loyers
qui n'ont rien à voir avec ce qu'elle
payait en 1980 des entreprises qui
paient des frais d'informatique n'ont
rien à voir avec ce qu'ils avaient en
1981 et eu aujourd'hui le consommateur
est beaucoup moins fidèle qu'est-ce qui
pouvait à l'époque et tenant compte de
tous ces facteurs là il faut oui revoir
si les distributions des revenus qui
prévalait en 1980 sont toujours viables
aujourd'hui ou si elles peuvent être
renégociés et pour ceux qui s'opposaient
à votre vision de l'entreprise ou de du
monde il y disait la loi du livre telle
qu'elle existe
elle protège aussi beaucoup le marché du
livre québécois les auteurs québécois la
création québécoise les éditeurs
québécois en forçant grâce à la
distribution une présence partout sur
l'ensemble du québec par exemple les
libraires à gré comme vous êtes vous
pouvez vendre des livres à bon prix à
toutes les institutions c'est un
avantage que la loi du livre tel qu'il
existe actuellement vous permet d'avoir
elle vous donne un marché assuré d'une
certaine et elle donne un marché
beaucoup plus important aux librairies
indépendantes comme chez elle parce
qu'il ya cette auto positionnement qui
se fait par des acteurs de l'industrie
qui n'est pas inhérent à ce que la loi
prévoit mme qui s'est établi au fil des
ans
maintenant on parle beaucoup du rôle des
libraires indépendants et de ce que ce
qui est une librairie indépendante
versus ce qu'est renaud bray la
dichotomie entre les chaînes et les les
indépendants je pense que les
indépendants un rôle un métier ont des
spécificités et que les librairies de
chaînes en l'occurrence celle de renaud
bray ont aussi une raison d'être
répondre à des attentes de la part du
public et qu'il faut aujourd'hui
reconnaître que ce sont deux acteurs
distincts dans un système oui les uns
et pendant peuvent tirer leur épingle du
jeu mais nous lui aussi et doit pouvoir
se retrouver dans cette industrie là
comme un joueur à part entière reconnu
les jets des milliers des centaines
d'employés qui sont là pour nous dans
certains cas depuis 20-30 ans qui ne
sont pas moins que les libraires
indépendants ou que les employés des
libraires indépendants et sont peut-être
pas plus mais ils sont au moins égaux
j'irai pour reconnaître le rôle de
chacun et une viabilité pour tous parce
que les libraires important que vous
êtes vous allé et avec la chad
d'archambault on s'entend pas tout le
monde qui ont ni 30% à 35% à 40% du
marché vous passeriez de 36 kursaal à 44
succursales
donc ça vous donne un rô le poids très
fort dans le monde du livre non ça donne
un poids très fort est-ce que ce poids
là est disproportionnée par le pardon au
poids qui existent aujourd'hui je ne
pense pas déjà les parts de marché dont
vous parlez je ne comprends pas
personnellement d'où elles peuvent
provenir vu que le chiffre d'affaires
d'archambault et confidentielle n'a
jamais été révélé que ce jour si vous
l'avez acheté je sais que j'ai tenus par
la confidentialité comme vous
comprendrez et ce chiffre d'affaires là
est composé de vente d'instruments de
musique de vente de cd de vente de dvd
de vendre d'autres articles au point que
je dire pour avoir vu les chiffres issus
de renaud bray sont déjà été révélé on a
toujours dit qu'on faisait aux alentours
de 120 millions de dollars de chiffre
d'affaires 600 millions qui même source
attention 620 millions de dollars
là-dessus d'affaires inclut aussi les
autres marchandises donc une fois que
vous avez enlevé le reste renaud bray
réalisons 80 90 millions de dollars de
chiffre d'affaires sur le livre sur 600
millions au québec on parle de 15% alors
et à ceux qui voient dans le
développement de votre bannière avec un
client scharbook peuvent créer une
concurrence ou une concentration devrait
agir très important comment peux vous
les rassurer à savoir que par exemple
dans certains endroits vous êtes en face
de mme archambault
on peut penser qu'ils auront
rationalisation quand c'est pas moi la
mode d'optimisation parce que vous vous
êtes un homme d'affaires vous êtes
décrite d'abord comme un homme
d'affaires est ce qu'on peut penser
qu'il y aura 10 kursaal qui vont fermer
éventuellement
écoutez l'objectif n'est pas de fermer
des succursales archambault c'est comme
j'ai dit un mix produits une clientèle
une offre nos vrais c'est autre chose
c'est contexte là où vous avez deux
succursales qui ont vécu l'une face à
l'autre depuis 20 ans pourquoi demain
matin ce qui aurait plus de place pour
les deux avec parce que je suis loyal
offre par exemple
chambaud il ya un certain nombre de
situations il ya deux succursales dans
une région limitrophe mais vous avez des
oeuvres qui sont véritablement
distinctes et j'invite les gens à les
voir cherche en bourse que c'est voir
chez renault brisk sens et mix produit
est fondamentalement différent notre
objectif n'était pas de faire un
objectif de fermeture c'est de maintenir
deux fleurons québécois envie qu'ils
sont complémentaires je pense que
l'existence de deux chaînes au québec
est quelque chose de tout à fait viable
et on ce qui est habile bibliodiversité
savait que jérôme ouvrir notre 30
magasins chacun de ces trente magasins
là à une offre différente une offre
adaptée un magasin de victoriaville qui
est beaucoup plus petit qu'un autre
magasin qu'on peut avoir à québec
les deux n'ont pas les mêmes titres puis
c'est pas vrai que le magasin de
victoriaville n'a qu'une petite partie
de l'offre de québec le magasin de
victoriaville ou de drummondville à des
titres qui ne sont offerts que là et pas
au québec parfois comme libraire est ce
que vous vous sentez de responsabilité
sociale culturelle pour la spécificité
québécoise avec peut-être un préjugé
favorable pour les éditeurs et les
auteurs québécois
j'ai un préjugé favorable par rapport à
la bibliodiversité est aujourd'hui
renaud bray et quand même depuis des
dizaines d'années la librairie au québec
à offrir la plus vaste sélection à
offrir un service de commande spéciale
pour ses clients parce que avec 400
mille cinq cent mille titres différents
sur le marché on peut forcément pas tout
avoir en stock mais on a investi très
tôt dans des services à l'attention nos
clients et pour moi notre responsabilité
sociale et leur envers nos clients de
leur donner ce qu'ils attendaient de
leur donner accès à la culture ce qui a
toujours été une mission qu'il est
encore aujourd'hui
hier j'avais deux anciennes miss lecture
sur mon plateau vous beaudoin et les
affres il a est l'une d'entre elles
particulièrement déploré le fait que
vous vendez toutes sortes de produits
on a parlé de babioles vous avez une
déclaration controversée au magazine
l'actualité qui dit que je vous si le
plaisir de la caisse en fait que sous
ces plaisirs de deutérium d'affaires se
serait à vendre des souliers ce sera
autant de plaisir pour gérer
l'entreprise
pourquoi renaud bray fait-il une aussi
grande place à ces produits autres que
le lit quand on rentre dans une ombre et
on voit très souvent beaucoup de de
produire aujourd'hui
enfin je vous dire de babioles mais
aussi des produits qui attirent le
consommateur puisque la fois l'aller un
étagement ne rien apprendre les livres
je conçois qu'il est juste de dire qu'il
faut aller à l'état joue en arrière pour
voir les livres évidemment on a des
succursales qui sont toutes de taille
différente de configurations différentes
il faut jongler malheureusement avec
l'organisation des lieux surtout qu'on
veut avoir des librairies en centre
urbain
par contre on répond vraiment une
demande de la clientèle j'ai déjà dit à
des enfants qui viennent chez nous tous
les dimanches qui ne vont pas dans les
librairies traditionnelles ou qui
n'aiment pas les librairies
traditionnelles parce que c'est un
espace relativement austère dans
certains cas surtout pour des jeunes
enfants d'avoir un environnement
polyvalent multi-produits c'est quelque
chose qui attire la clientèle
maintenant vous avez eu pendant des
décennies et vous l'avez encore aux
états unis en france et ailleurs des
librairies qui font 40% ou 50% de leur
chiffre d'affaires avec de
l'informatique et je n'ai pas vu encore
se faire accuser d'être des vendeurs de
babioles jeudi renault vrai c'est quand
même le plus important vendeur de livres
au québec le poisson quand on voit la
plus vaste offre mais c'est parce que
j'ai parfois l'impression de ressentir
quelque chose que de dénis grand alors
je pense que renouveler est devenu
aujourd'hui quelque chose grâce à ce mix
produit là qu'elle a été une des
premières librairies au monde à mettre
en place et à ausy promouvoir alors
qu'il est aujourd'hui maintenant le
copier part sur une autre chaîne
mais c'est peut-être parce que vous
portez l'image des déclarations vous
avez fait un comparant votre entreprise
bouh librairie au plaisir comme vous
auriez à gérer une entreprise de
souliers alors pour les gens c'est pas
tellement pas la même chose et qui a
même une loi du lit il ya un écosystème
du livre qui est protégé tout ça que
dont vous bénéficiez aussi quand même
j'ai dit que j'avais une passion
personnelle profonde pour le livre un
amour du livre mais que mon rôle de
président d'entreprise de gestionnaires
n'était pas quelque chose qui devait
venir en porte à faux être atténués par
mon amour du livre et je le crois
toujours georges des responsables des
gestionnaires d'entreprises quand même
de patron avec 1000 employés c'est ça
qui doit prévaloir dans mon travail tous
les jours et ce n'est pas non plus
complètement non conforme à la mission
de l'entreprise qu'est ce que vous aimez
lire toutes sortes de choses quand j'ai
le temps cette semaine j'ai pas encore
eu un moment mais j'attends de partir en
vacances sous peu avec quelques romans
coréen et vous espérez une réforme de la
loi
c'est ce que je comprend une réforme de
la loi de distribution des pouvoirs dans
l'industrie on verra de quelle manière
ça se posera je pense qu'il doit y avoir
un dialogue dans cette industrie après
je ne suis pas là pour imposer
unilatéralement des des règles des zones
où merci merci